very exciting nicole kidman is ready to
step into lucille ball's shoes
while the actress's casting as the
comedy icon
caused a little bit of controversy
earlier this month
she says she couldn't be more excited to
take on the role in the upcoming biopic
being the ricardo's which was written
and will be directed
by aaron sorkin i'm very happy very very
happy
in an interview with variety published
on wednesday
the oscar winner explained quote i was
like yeah i would love to give it a go
with aaron's words and his direction and
javier bardem playing desi arnaz
that's kind of a wonderful prospect too
you know
but yikes off we go give it a go try my
best see if i can do it
if you have passion and love for what
you do then that will carry you
carry you through anything news broke
earlier this month that nicole and
javier were being eyed to play lucille
and desi
the film will be set during rehearsals
for i love lucy
which nicole said she's been watching a
[Applause]
lot
[Applause]
i love lucille having looked now and
delved into her
she's an amazing woman i'm very excited
for people to see what erin found out
about her
and the way he's interpreted desi and
lucy and the way that it's so rich
i didn't know any of this i felt i
should just at least
try to calm the waters here um there
seems to be a lot of discussion about
nicole kidman it should be deborah
messing nick's interview comes shortly
after lucy arnez lucille and desi's
daughter
spoke out on facebook in an attempt to
calm down fans who were
all worked up about the casting choice
and flooded social media to suggest that
debra messing take on the role
instead yes yes yes
i agree not only has deborah expressed
interest on social media
she's also channeled the iconic actress
before
during an episode of will and grace that
aired in april 2020.
yes with vitamin regimen you can spoon
your way to health
all you do is take a tablespoon after
every meal
it's so tasty too
[Music]
at the time debra also shared this
behind-the-scenes moment from that
episode on
instagram hugging lucy on set writing
that she would quote
never forget this moment it felt very
much like
like a sort of nod to lucy and desi but
ultimately lucy said she was happy with
the current casting
and said she thinks fans will be too
just
trust us it's gonna be a nice film
and p.s the voting is over
i love all of you
you